you recall geometrical applications of
calculus is about a whole bunch of
particular Big Ideas big-ticket ideas
we've looked at one so far namely are
things increasing or are they decreasing
right we've we've looked at functions
we've looked at their derivatives okay
now stationary means you are neither
increasing nor decreasing okay you have
stopped not gone up I'm going down your
level for a second okay and importantly
it's a stationary point right I'm just
interested calculus allows me to think
about gradient at a single point right
right over one it's not rise you were
running everywhere but I can understand
it through the differentiation process
that we all know okay our stationary
points are really important they're so
important that many questions really
center around it and that should make
sense right if you're thinking about
something changing from increasing to
decreasing right or decreasing to be
increasing that point where it stops
that's a critically important point
right like you can get lots of
information about that like you remember
I said there are some particular
applications of these ideas that these
geometrical ideas and one of them was
optimization do you remember
optimization means it means maybe I want
to find the biggest value of something
right I want to maximize profits or
maybe I want to minimize something I
want to reduce the amount of income tax
whatever it is okay finding the
stationary point is often the key to
finding you know where is that important
place where I'll be able to get the most
out of my money or get the least number
of casual or whatever it is okay so
under the heading a stationary points
the important question that we get to
ask you is and this is all in all this
is it just informal language okay where
does if you're thinking about a function
right it's where does it stop as in when
does it become stationary and how like
in what way does it stop because things
can stop in different ways for instance
these two that I've just drawing on the
board they're two different way
stopping one of them is right at the top
of the function and another way is at
the bottom okay now where does it stop
and how we translate this into
mathematical fancy language and we would
say like an interpretation of this
translation news find or locate all
stationary points okay stationary points
tell me where they are we're right and
this question of will tell me tell me
what kind of a stationary point it is
tell me can you describe the behavior of
the station point because there are
different kinds which i'm going to show
you in a moment after you locate them
determine their nature that is the
phrase you will see happening again and
again which really means well it's
stationary but what kind of stationary
right let's draw some pictures we're
going to draw for really simply I've
actually already drawn two of them
already over there I will do this one
first and you can just put these all in
a row along underneath you're working
here here's our first two okay now as I
said under the idea of optimization for
you right in each case I've got not only
a stationary point but it turns around
okay but it turns around in a different
way this one the gradient is decreasing
in fact I'm going to put on that the
sign of the gradient right is i'm going
to write tongue and indicate green as my
gravy greenford radiant hope you can
remember that I'm negative negative
negative negative negative negative
right it's drop it it's decreasing in
that part of the domain right there at
the stationary point what's the
derivative is 0 right and then after 0
is positive positive positive positive
right so if my gradient changes in this
way the decreasing hits 0 and then goes
off and it's increase you okay we call
this on originally a minimum turning
point element
yes it's also cool we'll get to local
stuff in a minute I just want to get my
head around which way is it turning okay
in exactly the same way Green for
gradients ok this is doing the opposite
right my gradient going from left to
right it's positive positive positive
and then as you kids the stationary
point my gradient seer at that single
point right that would mean if I draw a
tangent that's what it'll be horizontal
ok and then negative negative oh you may
be negative okay so if I transition from
negative to positive on getting a
minimum on the other hand if I
transition the other direction positive
to minimum you can see I'm right the top
of the graph so we call this a maximum
turning point okay now don't draw this
just yet just have a look at what I'm
about to show you for this next moment
have a look at this are minimal Tony but
right the weights behavior is that for a
part of the young domain okay it is
negative negative negative but it's less
and less negative until it stops okay so
this is my letter inside here ok so
again going with my cranium negative
negative negative negative negative and
then 0 okay now if I turn round my
derivative changes sign becomes positive
right but I don't have to turn around do
I write like I've been decreasing and
decreasing you and then I stopped but if
I want to I could just keep on going
down I just like a lift does ok you're
on you're at the 10th floor and then
you're going down and then you slow down
and stop it you know second floor or
something like that but the list is
still going down right so it doesn't
become an increasing function also it
can keep on going in the same direction
like this okay so if you want to put
some Moss gown this this becomes a bit
hard right but inputs to the stationary
point I have a little little little
negative but then it gets more and more
negative as we go further away
so you can see this is still a
stationary point like it still stops
momentarily I still get a gradient of 0
but because my derivative does not
change sign this is not a turning point
because it never turns right now you can
see this is one case I could do it in
verse good and I instead of going down
stopping going down I can go up and then
stop and then go up in fact this looks
just like a very famous function you've
been dealing with for a long time what
does that look like looks like X cubed
doesn't it ok so right there I've still
got the stationary point right but on
either side I have a positive gradient
ok now um these two here are kind of two
different versions of the same class of
object ok they're called like to have a
couple of names but the name that I
prefer the one you'll probably see most
often is a horizontal point of
inflection now this is a bit of an
unfortunate name be in some ways just
for the sequence of learning things
because you don't you haven't talked
about what infection means just yet
suffice to say it has to do with the
difference between the left hand side
here and the right hand side they're
both decreasing but they're decreasing
in different ways ok when we go a little
bit further and we talked about not the
first derivative which I have in green
but the second derivative will drill
down further into this language ok but
just think of an excuse think of this
it's coming up it's slowing down and
then speeds up again it keeps on going
the same direction that's just the shape
you need to have your mind and we'll
deal with the language a little bit
later on yes
absolutely there is and also near I just
read your old points inflection that
another horizontal or vertical and we
will talk about the oil interview time
okay the reason why I'm dealing with
them now even though it seems like why
are we talking about it if we have to
wait until this discussion later is
because these guys still fall in this
category you see this stationary right
at that point there they stop and that's
what I'm interested in right now